no man's land into the middle of the
board why risk it
just keep your king on a safe swing i
think he can block that check with his
queen yeah you can even block this track
with your queen with your bishop
hand thing yeah lots of choice here for
wesley so he does block it with a queen
as you called
and yeah no transfer time if the queens
disappear then black's pawn actually on
that left side of the board will decide
the game by running forward and
promoting into a new queen so a queen
trade is off the table off the cards for
tamif we see the position repeat itself
i'll tell me if he's about to seal the
draw but that only helps wesley so there
we see wesley so wins today's match yep
a smile on his face wesley saw gaining
three points winning this match against
vladislav artemium i do see a smile on
wesley's face so that's nice he had a
tough day yesterday losing his match but
wesley so is back on track gaining three
points he will definitely gain at least
one point on magnus carlsen on the
overall standings
it could be two points if magnus cross
loses two m.l